Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
August 26th, 2013 what
he is saying, hey fuck,
oh, how are ya? How's it going? Holy Shit.
Where did the summer go? You
know, I always make fun of that.
I always make fun of people go, Oh my
God, can you believe it's already August?
Um, I worked my ass off to summer, so the
summer did fly by. I can't believe it.
I didn't get the layout or anything and
he'd get the Tan myself up and they get
to read myself up at all. You
know? Did you guys lay out Dick?
Get a little skin
cancer? Um, I am finally.
Okay.
I'm finally back in Los Angeles after
spending a month in New Orleans.
Uh, had a great fucking time down there
and did it with a on a great note.
You know, I settled my differences with
the city. I finally said, you know what?
You win. I'm going to have some
of your fried fucking food.
And um,
I ended up going,
I went bow fishing out in
the buy you a fucking bow.
And Arrow, right? I got myself
a six pack of Bud talls.
This is America, few people overseas
right now for you people over there,
I don't know what we did to you and
know what we're doing to you right now,
what we're gonna do to you in the
future that's going to make you fucking
passively aggressive,
aggressively attack the great
game of American football.
You know,
cause you won't get to the real core
of the issue that you don't like our
foreign policy. And by our, I mean me,
because I sit in on those meetings,
I'm making the calls,
you know,
and all you fucking cunts over
there who got cake every week,
every week I'm getting these fucking
emails that people still shit and acting
like NFL football players aren't tough
compared to rugby because they wear
helmets.
Do you realize how fucking dumb that is?
Okay.
That's like saying,
well you know,
so basically if you're in a car you can
drive it into a tree and you won't get
hurt because you're in a car. Is
that what you're telling me? Huh?
With all your portly fucking white
guys waddling around out there putting
shoulders into chess.
Okay?
It's not what we're talking about here.
We're not talking about a bunch of pasty
fucking white dudes running around who
can't even write a fucking five second 40
that's not what we're talking
about at all. All right?
We're talking about a game that is played
at his size and speed that is not seen
overseas. It just doesn't. You know
why? Because you're not big enough.
You're not fast enough.
And you know why that is.
Cause you never went to a country that
was bigger and stronger and force them to
come over here and do all the hard shit.
See what you guys did was you fucking
went to where they lived and you tried to
fucking build a castle over there.
Stupid, stupid fucking move.
Or what happened? You lost all
of it. So what do you do now?
Do you own up to it and just say,
you know what,
America's better at pressing the
world right now than we are now.
Okay?
You don't man up and say that.
You send me Cunty fucking
emails about a Goddamn game.
I've told you from the very beginning,
rugby plays is the toughest sons of
bitches. You know the tough, you know,
great fucking game.
I really enjoy it.
Okay,
well let's not pretend then of Leon let
right now rolled off the fucking couch
and decide to run down the fucking pitch
and some short shorts that, you know,
those guys wouldn't be falling over
on their backs. They would, I'm sorry.
It's bigger. It's stronger. Faster.
Yeah.
Hence, you know, and then you put a
helmet on. Now you've got a weapon.
That's all it is. It protects your
skull, but you fucking brains going.
What do you think they are? That
fucking thing. And next thing you know,
you're on the roof of your house when
you're 40 years old shooting at mall cops.
That's what happens to our retired
players. What do you guys do?
Huh?
Fucking get your ears fixed.
Okay.
Finally get that Wedgie taken out of
your ass. I don't know what you do.
Wait, when you retire as a
rugby player. I'm sorry people.
I'm a little grumpy right now.
Okay.
All right. Um, I finished
my, uh, my acting Gig,
my big song and dance number down there.
I'd like to thank Mike binder.
They've given me a shot on that thing.
Um,
okay.
And the second I was done.
Okay.
I ended up going up to Boston before I
came home because I had a Gig at the, uh,
the MGM.
Yeah.
Mgm Casino there in Connecticut,
not in Las Vegas.
I played the one in Connecticut, which
is like going to the University of Miami,
Ohio.
No kidding.
It was a great gig and I want to thank
everybody who showed up and everything
and I was in a fucking grumpy
mood when I came out on that one.
Okay.
I started shitting on Paul Versey. I
was going off on the traffic. I've just,
I just, I just really needed to
go home and have a fudge it call,
you know,
some conference.
I don't know what the fuck I
need and I'm still all wound up.
Okay.
Ah, fuck. Where the hell did this
fucking year ago? I got to tell you this,
I lost my shit. I know. I
started to tell someone, Oh,
both fish and I'll get back to that.
Remind me,
remind me to get back to
the bow fishing thing. Um,
yeah,
I forgot what the fuck I was just
going to talk about the, the traffic.
Yeah.
My fucking brain moves in a straight
line of very slow but it fucking line.
But it is a straight line. If I miss the
exit, it just keeps going and I can't,
I can't turn.
Um,
okay.
See it made me fucking forget the traffic.
Yeah.
I lost my shit like three fucking times
when I was up in Boston. All right.
I fucking hate that city now. I
love it. I love the sports teams,
but I hate that fucking city because you
land in it and the first thing you go,
you drive into is that big dig,
which is the biggest fucking scam
I did ever perpetrated when it comes
to fucking transportation. Jesus.
Talk my way out of that one, didn't I?
I didn't know where to go with that.
How the fuck do you shit on a highway?
These fucking assholes.
They just took everything. They put it
on the ground. They made it all one lane.
Everything's fucking one lane.
I don't know if there were anticipating
some, some plague or something.
I don't know what. But that thing like
this should just be like model t's out.
Oh God. Driving around that fucking
thing. They didn't add any lanes.
Every time I go in there, the
whole fucking thing. Shut down.
They got the Ted Williams tunnel.
You know what they should have outside
the head. Ted, Ted Williams tunnel.
They should have his head upside
down on a tuna can, you know,
like made out of concrete and tribute
to and then sell his family that we're
going to fucking leave that up there
until you give that man the proper burial
that he fucking deserves.
Okay.
So anyways,
you're going to fucking teddy ballgame
tunnel and there is enough room for like
five fucking lanes and there's only
two. And then there's this, this,
I don't know what this
bike lane for the obese,
what is the fucking e?
It's never opened.
And then the other one always
has cones on it. Sorry.
I've gone there like three
times his fucking year.
And no matter what time I drive in and
that this fucking traffic because of that
Shit, oh, I'm in a mood. I am
in a mood people, I admit it.
Okay.
And here's another thing.
I'm driving down to my Gig,
going down to the fucking MGM thing there.
Mgm Miami,
Ohio Gig that I had and I'm fucking
two 30 on a Friday afternoon,
should be wide open bumper to bumper,
fucking traffic,
you know, bumper to bumper, fucking
traffic. And I, it got to the point,
I literally wanted to roll down the
window and just an ask the guy next to me,
just be like, where the fuck are
you going? Don't you have a job?
Are you also a comedian? You know, are
you, do you work the fucking night shift?
Please tell me you're actually driving
a job and you're not just out here to be
out here.
Fucking come back from the MGM thing.
I get myself for fucking hours
to get up to Logan Airport. No,
three hours to get up to
fucking Logan Airport.
So I'd have a two hour fucking window
to get to my goddamn plane and I and
I ended up getting in bumper to bumper
traffic.
The second I get near the South Shore
Plaza bumper to fucking bumper traffic.
It's like 1230 in the
afternoon on a Saturday.
And where the,
where the fuck,
what of those fucking idiots sat
in traffic Monday through Friday?
Did are they,
do they like sitting in traffic?
It actually made me
look up the population.
I was like his is the population
exploding in this country because I didn't
think it was,
we were doing that bed.
I started doing the road hardcore around
97 98 we had about 267 million people
would just say to 68 okay.
Before I get some country email from
somebody who works from the Census and now
we're up to 313.9 so
we'll call that three 14
all right. So what's said no,
Jesus is going to do some math.
That's 32 million plus 14 million.
That's 46 million people
spread out over 50 states.
I don't fucking know if that's the
problem with white boy. I'll tell you,
they're all out on the highway.
It's almost worth being president,
you know,
just so you don't have to
sit and fucking traffic.
It's almost worth just
becoming an absolute yes men
and signing off on shit like
spying on American people,
being able to put American citizens,
citizens in jail indefinitely without
a fucking trial just because you think
they're a fucking terrorist. It's almost
worth doing that. You know, Jesse,
you don't have to sit in the traffic.
Maybe I'll just get like
a helicopter license.
I'll get one of those little
two seater once, you know,
basically the smart car of uh,
air travel
did. They, did they,
there's a lot of flat fucking things out
there that you can land on structures
and what are people going to do if you
land on their roof and just repelled down,
willing to call a tow truck.
Hey, you can't leave it to,
I just did.
We'll be back at 20 minutes.
You don't even know who the
fuck the call about this.
We're going to call the cops.
You got to stay in here with your hands
on your hips there. That is a helicopter,
you know. Well fucking keep it. I don't
give a shit. I'll get another one.
All right. Costs me 400 bucks. Look at it.
MMM.
And I'm sorry,
this is just all,
this is what being away from
your shit for a month, dusty.
And then you come home and you have
a mountain of junk mail. You know,
I realized that my mail,
nobody sends me anything nice.
I don't get one fucking, hey,
just thinking about, yeah,
I guess that's emails now, you know,
back in the day when somebody would just,
you know, cause you couldn't call him,
had to have some fucking jerk off.
Right? A pony with the Goddamn, I
didn't ride a pony. Rode a horse.
Why did they call it the Pony Express?
And I would tell you guys,
when I was a kid,
I thought a pony was a little horse.
And eventually it grew into a horse.
So he's fucking people down the
street at a pony. It was ridiculous.
He had it tied up to the back of their
house. I don't think they had a fence.
Fucking, I'll maybe the little bit of
offense listening, just stood there.
Okay.
With drive and buy the thing for years.
And I finally looked over at my mother.
I'm just like, I'm like one of one, does
that pony going to turn into a horse?
She just sort of looked at me,
you know,
I didn't realize that look when I was
a kid, but I realize it now where's,
she just was like,
okay.
She was literally looking at me like,
who did I meet with that, that d that
came out of me and just asked me that.
Oh Shit.
Anyways, so I want to thank
everybody who came out to, uh,
the MGM and, uh, Connecticut,
wherever the Hell I was
fucking beautiful out there.
That's the one thing I do like.
And then one thing I really do miss
about living out here in La is a,
I miss all those trees and the lakes.
I love that shit.
Okay.
You know,
I'm gonna be one of those douchebags at
fucking sells his house here in the city
and just goes out and gets a ranch kid.
Even fucking change a light bulb
by the whole outfit, you know?
Okay.
Big stupid cowboy, handsome chaps getting
in and out in and out of my prayers,
you know? No, I can drive my
old truck. That's what I do now.
Before I went in town to get provisions,
I just roll around in the dark to make
it look like I was actually out doing
something.
Okay.
Oh Christ. Um, anyways,
oh, you know what? Let's,
let's bang out lumps, bang out a
little fucking a shit. Wait, no, Nada.
You know what? I started talking about
the bowl fishing. Let's, let's finish it.
So my last night there,
I get invited out to go fishing and uh,
I was just like, yeah, I'll fucking do
that. Shoot fish with a bow and arrow.
I have, I don't know how to do that,
but I would like to know how to do it.
Why not? Right? So we
fucking go out there.
It's like a group of,
uh,
four and we meet these
guys at a gas station.
You got to get a fishing license
and all this shit. And uh, you know,
I got a six pack of Budweiser. I mean,
you're getting on a boat. I mean,
you have to, where I'm from, you have
to do that. If you're getting on a boat,
you have to have a six pack of something
and you've got to drink it or else
you're an asshole. So I got it.
And one of the guys is like, dude,
you're going to have a weapon.
Okay.
It's like,
yeah,
well I'm not gonna be pointing it at
you or me pointed at the fish. Let's,
let's try to make this a
little sporting here. You know?
Good. It's not like I'm taking a stick
like Tom Hanks in that fucking movie.
What he talked to the soccer
ball cast away. Well, sad, right?
Did we went out on this
fan vote? Yay. Nay.
All the way out in the fucking buy you,
it was terrifying.
It was fucking to second we got out
there was, because we did it at night.
It was a full moon was the shit,
you know what I kept thinking of,
you know that movie southern
comfort with powers booth.
That's what I thought about and I've
felt good that I was thinking about that.
Not Deliverance cause I feel like
that's Hacky at this point. You know,
one fat pasty dude gets banged in the
ass in the woods and nobody can remember
southern comfort after that.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I think it's high time that
stops. All right. So anyways,
um,
okay.
It was, it was, it was amazing.
Basically when you both fish,
I don't know, I don't know
where to even begin this shit.
The guy had like a flashlight,
one of these born in the by you guys
and he go right there, right there,
right there,
right there to the bone arrows
trying to shoot some fish.
That was this fucking chilling out.
And uh,
basically what you do is,
is you shoot wherever you,
wherever the fish looks like it is,
you shoot like five inches below
it because it's an illusion man.
Cause a little water. So it took a
little bit of time to get to use that.
So what I did was I started aiming it all
these small fish just bring in the bow
up cause I realized I was just shooting,
I wasn't aiming,
I was just kind of shooting in the
general direction. I kept missing.
So I was practicing on the little fish.
I didn't shoot at him.
I would just bring it up just to get the
muscle memory and a, I did all right.
I hit, I hit three and about, um,
three hours average, like one an hour.
It was a lot of looking for them.
I'm not going to lie yet, so I wasn't
that bad, but I missed a lot. Yeah.
MMM.
But I got three including one.
We fucking pull this thing in and it was,
uh,
had an alligator face and the back look
like an eel is call an alligator gar.
The thing looked beyond evil,
look like a fucking dinosaur.
And we got in a boat and they're like,
all right, watch out. Watch your feet.
Don't let it bite you. Don't let it bite
you and all that shit. And he's like,
dude, you got to get a picture with
that. You got blood on your face.
It looks fucking awesome. Everybody's
saying all this shit. You know,
I got to tell you,
you tap into that inner fucking caveman.
Cause when I went out there,
I immediately had this sinking feeling
like I can't go back to fucking the
village without bringing home
something to eat that's still in me.
And the village was my fucking hotel
room where I have room service.
It was fucking stupid.
But I literally felt that I don't want
to be the guy that doesn't fucking get
something. So anyways, it's
now feeling like a fucking man,
cause I killed this God damn thing.
And uh, I dunno. So I'm like,
all right, so what do
we do where, you know,
we killed a bunch of fish and I asked the
guy, go, can you, you guys are going to,
you know,
clean these things.
You put the fucking meet on ice or some
shit and ship it to me and the guys just
like, yeah, no,
Nah.
So then I was like, well, what the
fuck would you Saudia killin shit.
And it just kind of bugged me.
Oh No. What's going on here?
How come I'm not getting
any readings here?
Yeah,
I think it's recording. What the
fuck is going on with my mixer? Oh,
was it just saying it's really loud. What
is this? What is this? Come on. Come on.
Talk to me.
What's wrong with my
mixer at Jesus Christ?
Now I gotta I gotta shut this off.
I'm going to splice this together.
You're not going to notice, but I gotta
make sure I'm recording here. Hang on.
All right, so it was recording and I'm,
what the fuck's going on with the mixer?
What did I do? What did I do too?
It gives a shit. So anyway, so yeah,
so at that point I was like, all right,
well I killed three of these things.
The other two that I shut, they will
fucking beautiful. Really thick.
And I was like, you know, if
I'm going to kill these things,
I want to fucking eat it. I just want to
be putting holes in shit. But I anyways,
the, I guess that alligator Gar think
can survive out of the water for a couple
hours. So we were able to put that one
back or they said they were going to,
so I don't know. That's the only
part I didn't like. Other than that,
it was fucking great and uh, yeah, it
felt like it was in like a Mad Max movie.
Thoroughly enjoy it. Just next time I
do it, I only want to kill like one,
you know, or killed like two
or three and then fucking
okay,
clean up, take it in, fucking eat it
for the week. Does that make sense?
That's how it made me feel bad was I went
home and I looked up the alligator Gar
and I was waiting for it to be out of
the most vicious fucking alligator eel
this side of the fucking Mississippi,
Yada Yada. And they did, it was just like,
yeah, it's kind of, it's
very docile if it sees you,
it's shy and swims away.
I was like, Oh man,
I shot a fucking nerd,
an ugly nerd fish with an arrow.
And I judged it because of its face.
Like it was evil, you know? I don't know.
Okay.
The people I went with, they
also hunt wild pigs. That's,
that's something else I could shoot.
I could shoot a fucking pig dear.
I couldn't do that. Who's kidding?
Who? If I was starving I could do it.
You know,
she would have fucking cat if
I was hungry. Hungry enough.
Does anything I learned from reading
that fucking book fly boys and no,
that's not about a boy band.
Okay.
You know what's up Brooklyn?
We are flow.
I'm sorry,
I saw the vms were on tonight.
What's the deal with venues?
I know a lot of people say this,
but doesn't MTV have a lot of fucking
balls? They don't show videos,
but they still have their
video music awards. You know,
I know that's completely hacky, but
like I actually saw some of the videos,
I'm like, he's a fucking great
videos. I wish they would show them.
Where can I see these? How do I know
this music is out? Where do I go now?
Can anybody help me? Oh,
Kenya. Um, all right,
let's do a little bit of advertising
here for this week, everybody. All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Darla,
there are so many things in
the world that irritate me.
Traffic at two 30 in the afternoon
on a Saturday or a Friday.
You know, stewardesses who just
love talking on that microphone.
We want to thank you for flying. American
Airlines are flying time two days,
three hours, 22 minutes and 18 seconds.
He's going to be a time different.
Shut up lady.
Um,
when so many things can irritate you.
Why add razors to the list that
doesn't make any sense, does it?
It's time to stop
milking your razor blade.
Everybody I know with brand name razors,
you're used to paying outrageous prices
and exhausting those raises until they
start to look like rusty soda cans
and start carving up your face there.
It's time to move on.
Move on to a better world.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month. Everybody never think
about it again. They send a pack,
they send a pack every so you can change
your blades every week. That's not me.
That's missing a thing.
They send you a pack every month,
I guess is what it's supposed to be.
So you can change your blades every week.
I love these guys and your
face will love them too. Uh,
they also got a brand new
product called one wipe Charlies.
You know,
if that line was in the movie platoon,
that would probably be really
offensive. Way One wipe Charlie. Um,
it's a buttwipe for men.
What?
Okay.
And it's classic. Check out the
video for that. There's no way.
There's no way that's
true. No Way. That's true.
They got a new book. I hope it's
true. One one wipe Charlies.
It's a buttwipe for men.
What about women?
They supposed to walk around with a
stinky ass or you trying to say that they
wipe their ass is better. Oh my
God, the sky is falling anyways.
I guess they're classy.
Check out the video for that.
If you're in a scat and sign up for your
razors today, go to dollar shave club.
Forward slash birth.
That's dollar shave club forward slash
burr or go to bill bird.com and click on
the dollar shave club banner.
I really hope white one check one one
wipe Charlies was a joke cause that's
hilarious. You need
baby wipes, baby wipes,
the poor man's Butt Day.
Um, Hulu plus everyone.
I'm sure you've tried hulu.com but
I want to tell you about Hulu plus.
Hence the title Hulu plus who will plus
lets you watch thousands of hit shows
anytime,
anywhere streaming on your TV or on
the go with your smartphone or tablet.
Why stand in line or ride a train
and just stare at your feet.
Why would you want to do that when you
can be watching your favorite shows on
Hulu? Plus Hulu plus is a great way
to binge watch your favorite shows.
Hulu plus has tons of episodes from
break comedies like SNL community,
modern family, South Park, family
guy and thousands of other shows.
Hey,
how much is it a month?
Seven 99 that's seven
99 $7 and 99 cents okay.
Before you think it's really expensive.
All right.
For all the shows and movies you can
watch. Catch up on current shows,
BenchWatch on old favorites
or catch a great movie.
You can do it all on Hulu plus right now.
You can try Hulu plus
for a couple of weeks.
Free on me when you go to the podcast
page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on
the Hulu plus banner or go to
Hulu plus.com/bill all right.
Please make sure you use,
you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you can
get an extended free trial extending it,
stretching the defense,
throwing the long ball on first down
here so they know that we sent you.
All right. There you go. Hulu
plus.com/bill one more here he voice.
Okay. If you're an entrepreneur
and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're in a
high rise window view fancy pants office?
Of course you do.
Once you want to do that or do you want
to wait or do you want them to know
you're sitting in your underwear
like me right now doing this podcast?
You don't want that.
You want to come off like
a pro with the voice,
you can create the appearance of an
entire building, sales, customer support,
tech support, you name it sounds
like he got the whole damn thing.
Give your customers the royal
treatment with he voice.
A voice will forward
business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are, he voiceful find you.
It's kind of creepy.
Don't have time to take a call.
It's routed to a voicemail and you can
read it at your convenience as an email.
He voice not only gives you
an edge over your competition,
it takes away the edge the big companies
have over you right now because you can
pretend to be just as big as they are
and now you can try he voice for free for
30 days.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and use the
Promo Code Bill B I l l e Voice Promo Code
Bill,
or just go to the podcast
page at [inaudible] dot com
and click on that he voice
banner. God Damn you all
right. Back to the podcast.
Yeah, so there you go. You can
add that to my list of skills.
Okay.
All right.
I can bowl fish hunt.
Okay.
Provided somebody shows up with the
ball in the air and has the boat.
Okay.
That's not bad. Right?
That's a good skill to have.
One of the dollar collapses and I'm
out here in the desert with no lakes.
Well I can modify it then.
You know what the fuck would I shoot?
What can you shoot? That's not a fish,
but it's like a fish and it's out of the
water. I know a toddler. There you go.
And you know what? I wouldn't be
killing more than I was going to eat.
I'd only take one. Bill. Why are
you talking about cannibalism?
Cause I just read an amazing
book called fly boys. Uh,
Jesus Christ. What a book,
what a fucking book that was.
It's unreal. Everybody has done
horrific things around the planet.
Like right now how we
sit and they're given a,
yeah,
the powers that be shit over
there in Syria, Damascus,
whatever the fuck it is for
possible using chemical weapons.
I Dunno,
some of the Shit we've done.
We got a lot of fucking nerve.
Yeah.
Is this thing recording? What is with
my God damn electronics this week?
And I know, you know what bells
stop blaming the technology.
Why don't you man up?
Um, yeah, you gotta read this book.
It's really just balanced and it just
shows the fucking horrific shit that
basically the, uh, the the Americans
did and the Japanese did to each other.
And then also the unbelievable
heroic stuff that they did.
The whole God damn thing,
every color of the rainbow. Um,
I don't know how to talk about it
without fucking ruining the book.
MMM.
I Dunno, it, it just, uh, I can tell
you one fucking stories can help.
Douchebags aren't going to read it.
If you listen to this podcast is no way
you read. I'll tell you one quick story.
All right.
This will probably take two minutes.
If you want to fucking fast forward.
They're going into bond.
This god Damn Island shaped
like a horse shoe, right?
And the thing is, is what? They're
bombing. All right. He's right in the,
uh, like, you know, you know what a horse
shoe looks like, right? Sure. We all do.
We all have a fucking crazy uncle. It has
a horse, don't you? Or a pony. All right.
The bottom of the horse shoe,
not the two ends with a luck runs out
if he's hanging upside down right there.
Like you're going around the going around
the corner, right, right down there.
What part of the Horse Shoe was
that called? You know, it's funny.
People do crossword puzzles. Know what
that part of the horse shoes called.
Anyways,
that part down there,
like if you're pouring water into a
way where would gather we got it Phil.
That's where the fucking
radio station was.
And they had to basically fly right
into it. All right. But on the sides,
that's where the mountains were.
They were actually above where
the airplanes will, they'll just,
the mountains on the sides were so high
up and these guys had to come and so low
that the antiaircraft fire was coming
down on them and these guys had to have
the fucking balls. 20 years
old, 1920 years old to fly
in there and just be like,
well, they're not going to get me. The
other guys got to get it and no one full.
Well that if they got caught, they were
going to get fucking tortured and just,
they basically told them
to keep one in the chamber.
It just fucking blow your brains out
because if these guys catch you after the
Shit you've done, um, you
know, because once, once, once,
once airplanes got involved,
uh,
I guess way more civilian started to get
killed. And I know that sounds obvious,
but like I never really
thought about that.
I thought back in the day like
the revolutionary wars. I mean,
I thought people just,
you know,
just indiscriminately raped and
pillaged and went all the way around.
I guess she could, but uh, you had
to be a man about it, you know? Yeah.
He kicked open the door,
you know,
kill a couple of males and then tackle
somebody in a house coat, you know,
all kinds of scratches. Do
you face? I mean, yeah, you
fucking got, you got dirty,
you got dirty back in the day. Then all
of a sudden the advent of the air, Ariel,
Ariel type plane there,
right.
This does this sound as dumb
as it sounds to me out loud.
They fuckin you could just fly over,
you know.
Okay,
you're trying to hit a
warehouse yet a house.
You blow up a couple of babies and stupid,
they fucking hated these pilots.
They thought they were cow, that,
that thought they would devils and uh,
so they didn't want to
get caught or whatever.
So this fucking guy is
flying in antiaircraft fire
comes in the flack as what
they call it,
fleck.
That's what I call my boss would give
me shit for not unloading a truck quick
enough. That's what I called
flack. At 20 years of age,
these guys had such big balls,
that's what they call people trying to
shoot down the fucking airplane they were
in.
So it's basically like softball size holes
that go on through this guy's fucking
wings and he loses it and
he goes into his spin.
So he tells the two guys in the
back that they got to bail out to,
he's got to do this move
where he brings up like the,
the the fucking flap on the right wing
and then something with the Rodrigo.
They basically causes the plane to kind
of go sideways and it gives these guys a
chance to open the door in the
back because if they couldn't,
the air pressure would like hold it tight.
So the guys doing this move as the front
of his plane is on fire and the flames
a lap and at his feet he's doing this
maneuver so his buddies can get out and it
works. Both his buddies jump
out and now the fucking plane,
it's almost going to hit the
goddamn water. It's in a flat spin.
This guy takes off his seatbelt,
he's still fighting it.
You take the seatbelt off,
that's the last thing you get out.
And at the last second he catches it and
he comes out of the spin raw and goes
up and then he looks back,
seen as two buddies fucking landing in
the water and they're going to swim and
get taken prisoner by the Japanese.
And the guy was completely
okay.
You couldn't eat.
Unconsolable landed on the
aircraft carrier was just balling.
Just all he could say over and over
again was I took my seatbelt off,
meaning I was going to bail out. It was
just, you know, it's just fucking, I,
I butchered that story. Just imagine
someone who could actually write,
telling you that story.
It's a fucking unbelievable book.
It'll make you a better person
when you read it. And, um,
Jesus Christ,
I,
I think I'm going to read a whole bunch
of books on World War Two, no spin and in
and, and like the, uh,
the part of the war.
I wanted to say specifically the Pacific
Ocean and I just don't feel those words
go,
go together well.
Okay.
Particularly the Pacific Ocean part of
it, cause I, all that shit. Okinawa.
He would g might,
I don't know where any of that shit was.
They had a map and everything. You
don't dummy like me. Actually it was,
it was really,
if
it's all going to be a book like that
where they show the dirt on both sides.
That's the kind of shit that I like.
Okay.
Just fire bombing cities.
This is fucking unreal.
You know,
you basically on both sides in a war,
if she got war criminals and then whoever
wins gets to prosecute the other one
going,
how could you be such a piece of shit?
And everybody kind of did the same shit.
Okay.
That's what I was saying.
The bow and arrows with the babies
basically when shit goes down,
like babies die.
It's unavoidable.
Does this make any sense?
It's this fucking horrific.
I'm like 300 pages down this fucking road
and you guys haven't read the book yet,
so you probably looking
at me like I'm a maniac.
Why the fuck is it so hot in here?
MMM.
Anyways, hopefully I'm able to get
this podcast up on time. You know,
last week I recorded it on time and
there was something going on with the God
damn recording. Wow. Who's
kidding? Who? You know what
that something was? It was me.
So I actually recorded it on Sunday and
still couldn't get it up until fucking
Monday afternoon. I'm the worst. All
right. What have we talked about? Oh yeah.
So I started reading up on all
this, this stuff about the, uh, the,
the war with the Japanese and shit.
And I didn't realize,
do you know that was like three guys,
three Japanese soldiers that
didn't surrender until 1974.
One of them wasn't aware that the war
wasn't over. We'll call him a bill.
That's some shit I would
have done. Uh, the other,
other two guys knew the war
was over, but they will, like,
I'm not fucking standard down until the,
the fucking Grand Poobah tells me too,
cause that's what I was told when I went.
They just were like,
Dudley do right's these fucking maniacs.
Okay.
Stayed in the woods for an
extra 30 years in their uniform.
Their guns still work. They still in
ammunition. Well of course you did.
The fucking war is over.
And every once in a while they'd run it,
some local fishermen and
they take shots at them,
local fishermen. It was just
like, come on man, let it go,
man.
It's over.
They would drop leaflets in there and
they were reading them and they thought it
was a trick.
Yeah.
Oh my God. Just sitting out there fucking
eat and squirrels for 30 goddamn years.
Yeah. Best friends like
are they gonna fucking Huh.
Okay.
What, what, what'd you
be friends without there?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'll give you the link to that shit
before it just butcher it anymore. Um,
if anybody else knows any really good
books about World War II where it's really
balanced.
MMM.
Cause I read a few, I read
this one. That was great. Uh,
I read the rape and Nan
King along time ago.
I read this Hiroshima diary about this
guy who was in that city when the bomb
hit.
Uh,
I ran another one. I like those first
part. Like people who were there.
I read one one time about
this Jewish kid who was
on the run with his dad.
It's a classic too. I forgot what the
fuck was called. I'm such an idiot.
But at one point he was kind of looking
at his dad and he was just like,
just die already. Cause he was, I dunno,
it was slowing them down or something.
He has his guilt about that. She
was fucking unreal. Actually.
It's Kinda depressing when you think about
it, but I'm out too. It gives a shit.
Hey, I got all caught up and breaking
bed. I didn't have AMC my hotel.
So why I came here just binge watched
all fucking three of them. Jesus Christ.
Is that the greatest fucking show ever?
I don't want to over hype it, but uh,
yeah,
fucking insane. I'm not going to
talk about, I know I shouldn't.
I should have said right
out of the back then.
I'm not going to say anything
that happens in them, but um,
I didn't think anything
was going to beat the wire.
I guess I put them on par because the
wire, just the size of the subject.
And how many different
angles they hit it from.
But as far as keeping your
stomach and absolute fucking nuts,
uh, I don't know if I ever saw a
show like, like this one man. Um,
it's kind of funny cause I always have
like quick little scenes of him and
that's all they would ever give
me is just like the little scene.
So I don't know what,
I don't know what's going on,
which is kind of perfect because
my character doesn't need to know,
doesn't need to know what is
going on and wouldn't know. Right.
Saw would just call me up and say,
just fucking do this. And I'd be like,
all right.
So I always end up watching
the episodes. I'm like, oh,
that's what the fuck that was for.
Um, that happened this week.
All right. So anyways, hey,
I'll put the red sox are coming out
to la, beat the fucking dog. Just,
I would've loved to go
into a game down there and,
and not war any red sock shit because
fucking la fans are such fucking
psychopaths. Well, maybe they actually,
maybe they wouldn't have beaten me
because I wasn't there with my children.
Fucking pieces of shit.
Good God Almighty.
You know I wanna know what the fuck you
want to know what happened out here.
I don't get it.
I don't get why that's that extra level,
that gang bang or vibe is out here.
There's gangs every fucking city.
Okay.
Are these like in la? I like these. The
only our southern California is just say,
cause I felt that vibe
at a charges game too.
Like is this like the only part of the
country where gang or into like sports
too.
You know,
you think he gets some hard, looks at a
fucking next, game it down everybody's,
they're having a good time.
Okay.
I don't understand it. They're going to
have something to do with neck tattoos.
Why don't you get the neck tattoo?
I say it was fucked up
when I was in New Orleans.
I saw two guys face tattoos
and I couldn't believe how uh,
okay.
Unshocking they were at this point.
I've seen so many people with
face tattoos at this point.
This guy literally had one right in the
middle of his forehead and it wasn't a
good one.
You know,
Jesus Christ. I thought I was dedicated
to being a comedian or whatever.
You put a tattoo on your face.
I mean that you've limited yourself to
I get either working in a tattoo
parlor or doing just illegal shit.
Right. That's kind of a good way, you
know, if you ever think that you don't,
you don't, you don't have the
balls to stop following the heard.
Just get a nice, you know what?
Don't do it. Don't, don't do it.
I don't want to suggest to you get a
fucking face tattoo. Please don't do that.
Can you? Can you please not do that. Um,
did I mention I was at the
University of Cincinnati last night,
Saturday night by the time he gets it.
So it'll be two nights ago.
I want to thank everybody
for having me out there.
What a fucking beautiful school that is.
Okay.
Absolutely gorgeous man.
I love those. Those,
they have like the perfect size football
stadium and it's like built down in it,
so into the campus. You know, she
come walking by and it's really open.
Like you can just walk right
into it. Um, had that same vibe.
Like when I went down to Florida state,
I like the students can like, you know,
run the stairs if they want to.
I love that shit.
I hate when you go to those places and
they got the stadiums like all locked up.
Um,
I was surprised when I went to Boise.
Okay.
You know, when I was trying
to look at the blue turf,
I saw a little bit of it that,
that the whole stadium was just
locked up like that. I think it boys,
he's a cool place.
Right.
What are you worried about
the meth heads coming in,
stealing the aluminum benches? Is that
what it is? It probably is. I don't know.
Oh,
by the way,
I want to thank rolling Stone magazine
for putting me on the cover this month.
It finally happened for me. That
was a, a big moment, my career. Oh,
we'll definitely have a link.
I know a lot of people don't
read magazines at this point,
so it's not a big deal,
but it's a big deal to me.
Finally being on the cover
of rolling stone. Um,
actually I don't,
I have no idea who that kid is,
but if fucking freaked me out
when I saw it. Um, all right.
What am I talking about here?
What do I got here? What am
I going to go to the, uh,
as the straight up it was for you to
fucking read one of these things here.
Why don't we do that?
Why don't we read a little fucking
letter full moon. Mr. Barr,
you mentioned something about the full
moon in last week's podcast and I would
cause the strange behavior.
I worked in an emergency room for three
to five years and when I started working
there, I thought that theory was
bullshit. You actually said both.
I don't want to make this guy
sound crass. He goes, I now know,
I now know what to be true. Every
month during the week of the full moon,
we get a surge of patients other than the
plethora of fatties that clog our
department. He spelled it plethora.
Uh, we get Weirdos, example,
a one legged schizophrenia man with a
suitcase of knives in a butane torch.
I don't even,
I don't even know why.
Okay.
Other than the other
than the Weirdos though,
we have a lot of really sick patients
come in. There are more strokes,
heart attacks and other
serious health related issues.
I have recently heard a theory on
why this is from another healthcare
professional. Well thank God you
went in this direction buddy.
Cause I thought half a fucking second.
You were going to put this in my lap.
All right. Cause I have no
clue about any of this shit.
Um, all right. What do
we got here? He goes, I,
I to take a lot of what I hear is fact.
All right.
The theory is the theory is this,
even our blood has its own tide.
Yeah.
Jd says Christ,
why don't I read up on science?
This is like better than any
fucking movie. Just the truth.
Okay.
What do you mean it has its own tide
when it goes out as does
that when I get lightheaded,
is that what you're
talking about? Uh, he goes,
this may be minuscule.
I love that you're spelling all these
words wrong and you fucking work in an
emergency room.
Uh,
but the lunar pole on our bloodstream can
cause a person with health slash heart
problems to be at a higher risk
for stroke slash heart attack.
It can also cause behavioral changes
because of the change in our bodily
function and our body function.
Whether this is true or not,
I cannot deny three and a half years
of dealing with hell every week.
The full moon appears. Thanks for the
free imitate entertainment and the lefts.
So that's really interesting.
So like,
yeah,
if that's true. So when there's
a full moon, that's like a,
when societies like menstruating,
that's our once a month.
Yeah.
Like everybody just acts
like a fucking maniac,
a one legged schizophrenia with a suitcase
full of knives and a butane torch.
Jesus Christ. Doesn't that
sound? That sounds like,
what the fuck was that movie Mickey
Rourke was in that? Look like a cartoon,
but it wasn't. Jessica Alba had the
chaps on and she was a stripper. But you,
she still looked like you
could have her as a girlfriend.
And then there was that guy with the
yellow head and the red eyes for some
reason.
Remind me of the guy who played Beretta.
Do you know I saw him when I was out here.
I saw Robert Blake.
That's a hell of a thing.
Ryan to a guy or fucking killed somebody.
Okay.
What did he get off? I Dunno.
He fucking did it. Jesus Christ.
You're going to do a spaghetti Freddy's.
You know,
you got to take a piss and all of a sudden
you girlfriends shot in the head and
nobody saw anything and you found her.
C'Mon.
C'Mon Beretta for reals. Come on. Um,
alright. Wisconsin's a rod.
Yo Billy red face. Love the,
and I would love to paint another
picture of the AE rod story. Alright.
My version is with no,
Ryan Braun.
I live in Wisconsin where Aaron Rodgers
and the Green Bay packers are basically
a gift from God. I am a Chicago
bears fan, so I think basically,
so I think they're all cunts. Sorry,
I'm really reading worse than usual.
Um,
all right.
Brian who also got popped for PDS had
opened two restaurants with Aaron Rogers
called the eight to 1208 12 [inaudible]
bar and grill since they were both named
Mvp and their respective sports. And
I'm gathering that his number is eight.
Is He a baseball player? I
don't watch baseball. Uh,
when the news broke about Braun getting
suspended, Wisconsin was enraged.
Not so much that he was cheating or
being the bad image to kids or whatever.
These parents who want to blame mother
the others for the kids' lack of luster
or athletic skills,
but because he lied to Aaron Rodgers,
that's fucking awesome.
They're Wisconsin has some great sports
fans and I love the fact that their,
their fan base owns a part of the team.
I where the fuck that works,
even though you know, none of them
are allowed in the board meeting.
It's probably just by name only.
And some day they'll realize how
bad they got fleeced. Um, anyways,
in the past month or so when it came
to the news reporting, the reporting,
this story, local NBC, ABC,
Fox and CBS affiliates,
within 10 seconds into the story,
they talk about lying to Aaron Rodgers
when interviewing fans about it.
All they talk about is, I can't believe
he would lie to us and even lie to Aaron.
Like everyone knows each
other on a personal level.
People need to quit talking,
taking professional sports too
seriously and taking it personally,
especially when they are
multimillionaires. Line to
other multimillionaires.
Google search some of this to get a laugh
at how brainwashed sports fans in my
state are come to show Milwaukee during
the football season to see for herself.
I've been up there. It's fucking great.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Um,
well look, I mean he,
how did he lie to Aaron?
Yeah,
they got in business together.
You know,
it's not like he got on their
football team and then he said,
well, you know, I'd like you to join the
packers as long as your steroid free.
They opened a business together.
I don't give a fuck what you do.
Just don't steal from the register.
That would be more lying to Aaron Rogers,
right?
Or do you think he actually sat down and
said, well listen, I have a great image.
You know,
last thing I needed to be doing is
hitching my wagon to some guy who's then
going to be a, a, you know, you
know, fucking hookers and uh, uh,
but somebody stick a needle in
his death. I, you know what?
I've never opened a business
as you can tell. I don't know.
I don't know how the interview
process goes, but I don't, yeah,
I don't feel like he'd lied to Erin.
Okay.
MMM. Maybe. Maybe they actually came
up with this. Maybe this is a good cop,
bad cop thing that don't with
this other guy plays the bad guy.
And then Erin sits at the bar looking
all dejected and the cheese heads walked
by and then they come in and they
buy more fucking Mozzarella sticks.
You know that that could happen.
Right?
I don't fucking know who gives a shit.
You know what the fucking thing is?
And I'm telling you, I'm pulling a Paul
Versey and I said this three years ago,
within 20 years,
everybody's going to be on steroids.
Everyone's going to be on Hgh,
okay? We're all going to be on it.
They're going to fucking get it to the
same way we'd is gradually becoming
legal. That's what's going to
happen with roids. All right?
And now how also if you smoke weed now,
if you have a vaporizer,
you just basically inhaling just
the shit that gets you high.
All right?
So it's doing way less damaged to sitting
down drinking a bunch of Budweiser
like I did on that fan bulb
out in the fucking buy you.
They're going to do that with roids. Back
in the day, you did some fucking Roids,
right?
You ball shrunk up and you went and you
punched a horse in the fucking face.
That's what happened. And now
they're, they're way more mellow.
Although fuck Jerry Rameys kids snapped.
I Dunno.
Jesus Christ.
That's another fucking Boston story.
You don't want to, when all these,
all these, uh, stories came out,
all this shit that's happened recently,
how was actually thinking? Well, you know,
this is the balance. We had
such an unbelievable decade.
It has to balance it out.
You know,
with all this horrible shit happened and
now and it's like now wait a minute now
it was nothing but horror. So with
those championships that made us even,
so now there's some horrible shit
common these last couple of years.
So you know what that means.
We're going to win some more championships
coming up. That's how I look at it. Oh,
by the way, any San Francisco
49 fans listening to this,
how do you feel about all fucking capper,
nick out there fucking on
the cover of every magazine.
Half naked with his fucking ass in the
air showing off his tattoos and his abs
doing commercials and
all that type of shit.
You'd think he won the fucking super bowl.
Have you seen one God damn
commercial with Joe Flacco? Huh?
Have you?
I haven't as a football fan.
I don't like when that shit happens.
I'll tell you right now,
once Tom Brady started
experimenting with his haircuts,
you walking around with Doug's going
to fashion shows. I don't know.
We have one 1 cents.
Doesn't that sound like some typical
moron shit that you'd hear on Sports Talk
Radio?
Lorena car I had when I was in Boston
was tuned to sports talk radio and I,
I can't fucking listen to
it. It's just a dumb, I was,
I put it on and they were criticizing
big papi saying he's a selfish player and
all it's classic Boston fucking morons
sports where it's just inevitable.
They're gonna eat their own.
You mean the guy who fucking helped was
one of the main factors in ending that
curse. The 86 year curse of the
Babe, all of that fucking horse shit.
That guy should be able to shit in the
street for the rest of his fucking life.
Not even 10 years later. You're
already saying that the guys selfish.
Shame on you. Boston sports
talk radio. Shame on you.
All right, let's get back to the
podcast here. Sorry guys. Um,
so I'm actually predicting,
Nah,
you guys might have a little bit of
a hangover there in San Francisco.
You coach is putting on weight,
right?
Filling out those dockers
more and more every week.
Trying to will his people to win.
Actually,
I think Catherine is going to do great,
but I always get nervous with
quarterbacks who run around like that.
Eventually those linebackers,
they get sick of that shit and a,
they get an open shot at you and
they, uh, next thing you know,
you're bleeding into your lungs.
Um, advice for a skinny guy.
All right, here we go. A day a Billy boy
first till that first time. Long time.
Thanks for all the last
there. No worries. All right.
It's great that you're helping out those
who are overweight by shaming them.
Is that what you're saying?
I've helped out a couple of,
I've probably had other people have their
face in a bucket of KFC right now. Uh,
but if I may,
I'd like to ask for advice for a guy
who's a little on the thin side of the
spectrum.
I'm tall,
six foot seven and weight
around 155 160 pounds. Dude,
I can't fucking help you.
You six,
seven one five. I weighed one 55
and high school and I swear to God,
I looked like I was going to
get blown down the street.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
Okay.
Even though I eat quite
a bit any regularly.
Yeah.
I even also have protein slash meal
supplement drinks in between though.
Don't fucking drank those things.
I don't know shit about no,
but don't drink those. Thanks. That's
fucking powder thing that comes into that.
That breaking bad fucking oil
drum. Don't, don't do that dude.
Okay.
All those supplements and all that type
of shit. Don't fucking do that. All right.
Just accept who you are. We all want to
look up a little bit better. All right.
Believe me.
Trust me on this one.
You're going to fill out all right.
It happens whether you want it or not.
So enjoy the fact that you can kind of
eat whatever the fuck you want to, but I,
I,
my gut tells me to,
I don't fuck around with shit like that,
that creatine and that,
that fucking muscle milk stuff and all
that shit. You turn it around the back.
You can't even pronounce
half the shit that's in it.
There's no fucking way that
that stuff's good for you.
There's no way that that thing,
it's going to be better for you than
sitting down eating a nice grass fed
fucking steak there. Um, granted,
I don't know shit about nutrition,
but I'm also not a fucking moron.
Okay.
Right.
Anyways,
he goes,
my siblings are just as tall as I
am and they are not been like me.
I'm also 23. Is that metabolism dude,
I'm not a doctor. I don't know. Well,
I pass this stage.
I don't know.
I am somewhat comfortable with myself
and I have a smoke and girlfriend of five
years. Well, go fuck yourself then to
come on. Who loves me for who I am,
but wouldn't mind a few pounds.
Oh, wait a minute. She bring it up.
Should I binge on Pasta?
Thanks bill.
I bought the raises because of you,
while I helped the razors workout for you.
Jesus Christ do with your height. You
probably need to order them twice. Um,
now dude, listen, listen, listen, listen.
You gotta be who the fuck you are.
All right. Would you ever say to
your girl like, Hey, you know,
I'd like it if you lost a
few. He can't. You know,
I dunno if she just made one comment
and forgot she even said it or she,
she's literally given you a body image.
But I'll tell you,
do one of the greatest things you can
ever do in life is except yourself.
All right? And I'm not
saying like, Hey, you know,
I'm doing something unhealthy to myself
and I accept it. I don't mean that.
I mean like, except what the
fuck you look like and uh, and,
and,
and just,
you know,
just be a good shit and it,
everything falls into place.
You don't need to go out there and drink
muscle milk and he fucking angel hair
pasta,
you know,
set your alarm and get up at three
in the morning and go eat that shit.
You're 23 years old. You're supposed
to be in good shape. All right.
Okay. So you're a little
fucking underwear. Who gives
a fuck? Dude? You know,
you're built like you built like
snoop Dogg, he seems to be doing fine,
you know?
Um,
I, I would, I would not
try to gain any weight.
I wouldn't try to lose any weight.
I would just just keep doing what
you're doing. All right. You're a guy,
you're six foot seven,
you weigh about 160 pounds at 23 and you
have a smoking hot girlfriend and loves
you for who you are.
And she made one fucking comment about
putting a few more pounds off by this.
Let, let that, let that go right by
you. I wouldn't even worry about that.
All right. You're a good man. You'll,
you'll look how you're supposed to look.
All right. Put that fucking
powdered nuclear waste away.
I don't know what the fuck that shit does.
The kidneys or your liver or whatever.
But uh,
no.
When the ingredients look like the last
name of Russian hockey players, you know,
or the fucking Swedes, I think the Swedes
got the most difficult names. That's,
that's a good time to fucking,
you know,
the only time to eat shit like that
is if you're orbiting the earth.
Other than that, you know,
go to a farmer's market
like a God damn human being.
All right. Organizing porn.
Uh, bill on a recent podcast,
you complained about the difficulty
of searching porn on the road. Did I?
I thought I was talking about how
I wanted to stop watching porn.
I might've said that on a podcast and
in the past and you just listened to it.
I don't fucking know. But recently
I've been trying to down on it,
I've been trying to watch an only on
Sundays and that's not a slap to the face
to whoever created all of this
shit. It's just, you know,
Sunday's a day arrest
and I like to be totally relaxed.
If I can open up to you guys a little bit.
I'm sorry. All right. Anyways,
he says as I also have a job
that requires me to travel a lot.
I know all too well.
The frustration of unreliable Internet
connections and the sheer amount of time
wasted on searching for
the perfect porn video.
So let me tell you about a little trick
I recently discovered paying for porn.
I know paying for pouring feels
counterintuitive, but it's worth it.
Um, here's what you do. Well,
this is the reason why and I'll pay for
porn is because I don't want my credit
card on the porn site.
And then if they double swipe it,
I don't want to have to call the credit
card company saying that, you know,
you just Dotcom fucking double swiped my
credit card and I'm really upset by it.
Or no, even worse, they call
me up, you know, you know,
did you a fucking, I don't know. I can't
even come up with a good fucking did you?
Uh, ass bag 9,000. Did
you fucking rent that? No.
Did you rent fucking scumbag
on the ass bag returns?
Yeah. Yeah, I ordered that one.
No, I'm kidding. I'm not into.
Amanda does get everybody
the German kind or the,
or like the shit that scat man Crothers
did I ever tell you how much I hate to
sketch thing?
I'll tell you one of the worst get
singers of all the time would be fucking
Frank Sinatra at the risk of pissing
off all the Italian Americans,
his scat singing at the end
of strangers in the night.
Doobie Doobie.
Do Toby di Di da Di da Da.
Yeah,
he sounded like Joe Piscopo doing him
before Joe even did it. Right. Anyways,
let's go back to this shit.
So let me tell you what I learned.
A little tricky thing.
Uh, paying for porn.
I know paying for porn feels
counterintuitive, but it's worth it.
Here's what you do.
Find a site that has the kind of
content that you're looking for.
Make sure that the site allows for
downloading and isn't just streaming only.
This is key. Download all your favorite
videos to an external hard drive.
Ah, Jesus Christ. Do it.
And then what the FBI kicks open the
fucking door and make sure you cancel your
membership before you're 30 days is
up or else they'll charge you again.
Once you've done all that,
you'll have a drive full of high quality
porn that you can keep forever and you
don't even need an internet
connection to watch it. Jesus Christ,
this guy might have some figured out here
between the external hard drive that's
50 to $100 and a one month subscription,
25 to 30 you're looking at about
80 to $100 initial initial setup.
Do that.
Math doesn't work out.
You're looking at 75 to $130 all right.
You kind of fucking alligator on both ends
of it. Whatever. I suck at math, so no,
actually I don't suck at that kind of
math. I suck at the kind that, you know,
once you have to learn how
to build a bridge, you know,
once there was shapes and there was these
paragraphs, right, you had to memorize.
Yeah,
I haven't did okay in Algebra.
If I wasn't such a jerk off,
it could have fucking got the c minus
and not have to go to summer school.
But that's a whole another fucking
thing. Also, I trashed the, for the, uh,
my teacher had a speech impediment,
so I used to make fun of them.
That was stupid. So when I kind of
had a 69, he didn't give me the 70,
and he fucked my summer.
Um, anyways, where am I?
You're looking at about $8,000
initial investment, but think of,
think of all the time and frustration
you'll save by not having to deal with
surfing for porn on the road.
It's changed the way I travel.
Yeah.
Dude, you sound like you just bought
the ultimate like neck pillow, pillow,
however the fuck you say that word, by the
way. I fucking hate those things. Yeah.
I hate you fucking walk around the
airport and those fucking douchebags have
those neck,
neck pillows are already around the neck.
I always just want to punch him right
in the nose because he already was like,
they have that neck brace on
a fucking lazy. Are you? Do.
You can't hold your head up when
you're walking around. Sorry. Um,
anyways, Bill, thanks for the
free hours of entertainment.
They've gotten me through countless
boring flights and cab rides. Well, dude,
so now if I fight, download, my
favorite ones were the ones who is,
when I find one that I really like,
I always forget the name of
it and then I can't find it.
And then I try to search like these,
I try to come up with words that describe
what I watched and that never comes up.
Like the search engine, all these sites
stinks. So maybe that's a reason to do it.
Uh,
and also if I want people
to pay for my fucking DVDs,
shouldn't I be paying these porn stars?
How would I be in a hypocrite? God, it,
I think, I think I've convinced myself
through youtube trying to convince me.
People, I think it's high time.
I'll come. Lars did our fall.
Rick didn't speak out about that.
Well,
I guess it wasn't happening to them back
in the day that Jesus, I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about
here. Um, all right. Overrated.
Underrated for the week.
Everybody guys using the term
slut to refer to his male friend.
That's overrated. As in
what? As in what up slut.
Oh, Jesus. Guys say that to each
other. That sounds terrible.
He said a kid I hadn't
talked to in awhile,
whom I was supposed to meet up with
in New York City dropped this on me,
and not only did I tell him
I didn't want to hang out.
I told him I wanted to connect my knuckles
to his teeth in a way that would send
them across time square.
Okay.
Oh yeah, it's bad. What ups
luck. That doesn't sound that,
that sounds like something one white
frat guy would say to another white Frat
guy,
you know,
and then do some bastardized version
of some my gangster side. Right.
Okay.
I got, I got a, I have
an underrated for you,
everybody watching reruns of Tj Hooker.
Okay.
Tj Hooker.
He's arguably the worst acting.
Yeah.
Ever.
On any show that ever happened or at
the very least I would put it up there.
All right. Well, let's say you had
the march madness of worst TV shows.
All right,
that anybody ever acted on TJ hooker
without a doubt would be a number one seed
in, in one of the regions
without, they would be like Duke.
Okay.
It's fucking horrific.
First of all was the episode I saw him
and the Armenian dude or whatever the
fuck his name is, who's pretending
to be Italian. Uh, Romano.
They get separated and they're on walkie
talkies and somebody shooting at Tj
Hooker and Romano is going in
into these call and Tj Hooker.
And I don't know why he's not saying Tj,
he just,
he's just going hooker and then they'd
show fucking TJ hooker with his fucking
awful to pay. We're half the show. It
doesn't even match his fucking side parts.
More gun play,
more gun play.
And they cut back to Romano
again and he's goes hooker
and then fucking captain Kirk,
any chance she gets to fondle and
get cheap fields on Heather Locklear.
He does it.
He rescued her one time and he was
literally like caressing her face just for
like fucking the final like 90 seconds
of the show was just rubbing the side of
her face.
And you can tell she's like a young
actress and she doesn't know how to say in
between. Takes like, Hey,
do you want to do me a favor and maybe
just have your hand on my shoulder just
for a second. Yeah, because it's,
I just don't feel like your
character and my character.
That's how you talk your
way out of somebody doing
something awareness scene and
she doesn't know how to do it.
Okay.
Just imagine them running around and
Larry Bird short shorts because they do
that also. And Captain Kirk is sucking
in his fucking stomach. What happened?
Don't, don't, don't, don't listen to
this here. Just sit down and watch it.
If you can find it on your right
and your cable. I'm telling you,
unbelievably underrated. Uh, by the
way, by the way, my tickets came,
my tickets came for
fucking Texas a and M uh,
Alabama college station. Me, dude,
I called it Paul Versey and uh,
two of my other buddies outside of the
business are going to go to the game and
uh, we're taking some fucking a, I'm
doing a couple of gigs. Oh, that's right.
I'm doing an El Paso part of the Billy
red state tour and then I'm doing,
um, uh, San Antonio. I've never,
I never been to either one of those,
either one of those states, states,
either one of those cities in that state.
So I feel like at this point
when I perform in those two,
I've hit them all right.
I've been to Dallas, Houston,
Austin, San Antonio, El Paso.
The fuck else is there.
I went to a game at the cotton bowl.
Right. I'm going to go see Texas
A and. M. Who else? I gotta see,
I gotta see Texas Tech.
I got to see the longhorns at some point,
but I went to the Red River game, so
I saw them. I saw him play Oklahoma.
I got to go to, I gotta go
fucking pig hunting down
there. You want to go pay gun?
We'll fucking do it, buddy. We got the
biggest fucking take back fake thing.
I got it. It's big. We're
in Texas. I get it. Um,
yeah. Oh yeah. By the way. You know
what? Um, now that I'm done with my, my,
my fucking, my glee shoot there.
Now I told you what it was,
it's called black and
white comes out next year.
I'm not going to bore
you with it because a,
it's not going to come out until next
year, but when it does, oh golly. Gee,
I'm a, I'm a hopefully get out of
the director Mike binder who's a,
one of my favorite comics
when I was growing up.
I hope they'll get them on the podcast
here. All right, hang on a second.
Let me go to my website here. What's your
website, Bill? Oh, it's bill bird.com.
Thank you for asking. Thank you for
being interested. Isn't that sweetie?
All right. Here's some of my
upcoming shows that I have. Uh,
cause they had to move around the red,
uh, the Billie red state tour. Um, oh,
would you look at that? All right.
Tuesday night, um, co headlining.
I'm opening for Brian Regan. It's
already sold out at COBB's comedy club.
All ticket proceeds go to charity.
Um,
which I dunno, I, I pitched it to him.
I always wanted to work with
them and I was like, come on Ma,
you know I lope before you will get shit
faced afterwards. And he goes, yeah,
we'll get the money to charity.
Yeah, fuck it, let's do it.
So hopefully if this goes well,
I'm going to start doing that with
some other guys I'd like to work with.
You know,
I'd like to do,
I'd like to work with other fucking
headline is that I love and I never get to
see cause they're always
out headline and write.
I'd like to do that with a couple
others and just do them, you know,
and then just do shows in the middle
of fucking nowhere. Um, all right,
so here we go.
September 4th a reschedule Billy Red
State a extravaganza at the boulder
theater. September 5th I'm
going to the Broncos game.
Why not open a game and the NFL season?
September 6th I'm at the Pike Peak Center,
Colorado Springs,
Colorado. That's also
a red state. Rebooking.
And then I got a the spotlight
29 casino in Coachella,
California on September 7th.
And I'll read the next week after that
I met the Abraham Chavez theater in El
Paso, Texas. That's a
red state one. And then,
cause I'm on my way over
to fucking college station.
Why not stop at the Lilla
Cockrell Theater in San Antonio,
Texas. I hope I said that right. I never
been there. I heard it's fucking great.
And um,
Paul Versey will be on both of those.
Um,
those Colorado dates in the a spotlight
Kasina will have Rosebowl legend and
cook.
Um,
Jason Lawhead who's just
growing by leaps and bounds.
It's one of my favorite things and
I'm watching the business right now.
The fucking guy's hilarious. Uh,
try and come out to those shows. Um,
that is it.
And that's the podcast for this week.
I was supposed to mention
at the top of the podcast,
because I know I have some new listeners.
If you like my shit and you'd like to
see my new standup special that came out
last year. Uh, or did it come out
this year? Last year came out,
you people are all the same.
You can download it for five bucks or
you can get your very own hard copy,
a DVD version for 20 bucks delivered
right to your fucking house,
wherever the hell you live, whatever
country. I don't give a shit. All right,
you can do that. Bill bird.com click on
the a, what is it? The merchandise button.
I said what it is march. Click
on March. That's it. All right.
That's a podcast for this week.
Have a great week.
Don't put that pottery shit and you got
damn drink. All right. Don't do it. Okay.
Go Fuck Yourself.
He'll talk to you next week.